[Music]
send it on out to Kevin Frazier who is
standing by the Playboy Mansion and with
the latest on Hugh Hefner's passing
Nancy lots of folks have been coming by
all day long to just stop here through
the gates and take a picture in front of
the Playboy Mansion here's the
interesting thing most of the visitors
have been overwhelmingly female you know
Hugh Hefner was much more than just this
mansion he was an icon he was also a
controversial figure and he was a man
who helped define the sexual revolution
to dream the kind of dreams I dreamed
and have them come true to make the kind
of difference that I've managed to make
in terms of society he's very satisfying
for me so I think I have to look on my
life and say it it's been our life well
spent
the legendary Playboy founder was 91
we're told he peacefully passed away
from natural causes at his home the
Playboy Mansion surrounded by loved ones
a source tells ET Hefner had not been
well for the last year and as far back
as 2006 Hefner always traveled with a
physician wherever he went this is the
last known photo of Hef he posed in his
custom-made silk pajamas with two of his
sons on Father's Day Hugh look happy in
this bun
snapchat video posted by his third wife
crystal in December of last year a month
earlier his son Cooper posted this
Thanksgiving photo Hefner avoided the
spotlight in his final years his last et
interview was in 2011 I am essentially a
very romantic person and I wear my heart
on my sleeve
there is no word yet on funeral plans
but et has learned that Hefner will be
buried at Westwood Village Memorial Park
in LA next to Marilyn Monroe in the same
mausoleum Monroe was on the first cover
of Playboy and today many of the women
he made famous are mourning his loss
Pamela Anderson who appeared on the
cover 14 times was in tears he printed
the magazine on the cover and it says
magazine more than anybody else and for
very good reason
I keep wanting to do s no paper girl and
Jenny McCarthy Playmate of the Year in
1994 called him a revolutionary there's
always those people in your life that
changed the course of your life and how
many people he affected I will always
miss you have and you will never be
forgotten
[Music]